[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
what are we doing out there huh
because I don't know no seriously but
what are we doing what are we doing
playing football
player football yeah
yo exclusive thing you need to let the
Menace take look at you man dude I'm all
right man I'm Fair
shoot like I'm here
and I'm ready to do this man all right
what about you all man do you want this
yeah yeah do you want that yeah yeah do
you want that yeah
I mean all you had to do was ask man
it's plenty of apple pie to go around
come on man you want a slice yo
exclusive team ain't no apple pie man
that's your helmet no no maybe you
should just sit down next place sit out
next play yeah are you all set up next
Lane ah you wanna sit after that fight I
didn't think so I don't need to sit out
the next Lane we'll tell you why cause
all y'all cause I know y'all got my back
y'all know what I see when I look at you
I'ma tell you what I see
grown man
who look like giants
what and just right there a few seconds
of complete darkness and then I saw some
little floaty specks of light in the air
up like this Exquisite team who is that
is that cartoon slow talking to me yeah
I'm here man you have a brain injury you
need to get some medical attention hey
I'm gonna tell you right now cartoons
flow who needs some medical attention is
the Cougars over there right there we're
playing the bruises okay listen y'all we
need to remember who we are okay
we're on a team with Destiny this year
we have a team everybody talking about
we had a team everybody afraid oh man we
got to remember who we are rhinos
oh my God somebody stole our horns we
gotta find a horse
foreign
welcome to the 2015 East West Bowl pro
edition of all the All-Star games in
professional sports this one is sure to
be the most extravagant that's right
these players were selected by the fans
too and when it comes to Flair these
characters are the creme de la crème
[Music]
Sean Wayne Clemson HaHa Clinton-Dix
University of Alabama
Dupree West Virginia University
of Central Florida
senior Central Connecticut State
University
Georgia Southern University the
birkenshaw Ferguson University of
Virginia
University South Carolina still Tavian
roboclick
Grambling State Cornelius Tank Carradine
Florida State University
begonia's Thicket suede Duke mama Dune
shazbot
Tulane University swordless mime town
Jacksonville State University
[Music]
there is a lot of talent in this game
Eric let me tell you something when you
look at Players like marmadoon shazbot
HaHa Clinton-Dix and strong plug it
you're looking at players who made an
impact this year I mean is HaHa
Clinton-Dix even real this guy was
amazing so solid all season long for the
Green Bay Packers and when you throw in
guys like Lagoon Dupree worthless mime
Town into brickershaw Ferguson this is
surely going to be a squad for the ages
I agree now let's meet the players from
the West
[Music]
Prince of mukamera University of
Nebraska
J.R Junior
Texas Christian University photos
University of Oregon
Fozzie Whittaker the University of Texas
myriad
profiteroles
Utah
[Music]
damn cupcake
man
you know hearts and they'll wash it it's
a small kitchen Kent State University
take it to them
limit
College of the Canyons
snark men's plots East Los Angeles
College Frosty Rucker University of
Southern California
Austin University
triple parakeet shoe Ball State log
jammer to baggage cling
North Texas University
A.A Ron Rodgers Cal
[Music]
and we're coming to the end of the first
quarter with the Rhinos in the red zone
for the first time gotta say Bill I like
watching these rhinos Ransom takes the
snap drops back with good protection and
that's a completed pass to a very wide
open ingleman crinkleberry the rookie
out of Penn State nice ground by
mccringleberry you think he's happy oh
boy he is loving it down there oh we got
something of a shooting gallery oh yeah
look at that boy that is something and
oh whoa wait we've got a flag though for
excessive celebration yeah well I see
and I'm not sure about that call I don't
know Bill that was three pumps in the
rule book says you cannot have more than
two oh my gosh but look at the kid he's
pleading his case
yeah clearly three Puck Coach Johnson
definitely not happy about this call
five minutes into the fourth quarter
third and ten the Rhinos again
threatening to score can the Cougars
hold them big play coming here Bill
Ransom takes the snap drops back he
floats one into the end zone and MC
pringleberry pulls it down he's got it
oh my gosh for his second touchdown of
the day for this rookie he has got to be
feeling great about himself I'll tell
you man he's oh let's see now there's
two pumps yeah he's really testing the
boundaries and he's clearly gotten the
ref's attention here a third pump will
draw a flag no matter what see oh he
just did it again no what is that the
second time now you have to flag him up
yeah he had to you know Bill it's it's
frustrating seeing young players without
the ability to restrain themselves it
really is it's hard I mean the ref's
gonna get you every time yeah yeah
absolutely I see now the ref agrees
that's three pumps right there
and the quarterback Ransom under Center
last five minutes of the game rhinos are
Marching here again hard to stop this
team from scoring bill they have so many
weapons
Ransom takes the snap and it's a shovel
pass the mccringleberry ooh he's at the
ten he's at the five and touched down
Rhino oh my great block by hard dunkac
shot and that's going to be tough for
the Cougars to come back from boy what a
career day from Hingle mccrinkleberry
the rookie out of Penn State oh he's
just amazingly fired up here today Jeff
you gotta love the way this guy plays
and he Oh see now there's one pump oh
well I cannot believe this kid you gotta
put your team first in situations like
this and the kringleberries just not
doing now there's two Jeff now if he
pops a third time he will draw his third
penalty for today
everybody here waiting with Betty breath
[Applause]
yeah that's what it is yes you can argue
all you want but the flag well it's been
thrown that's right if it's three pumps
the ref's not gonna take it away no he's
not duration and intensity doesn't make
a baby Jeff let's have a look at the
replay here to see if indeed he did do
the three pumps all right no question
there is the first one yeah right agreed
right and then coming up
is the second one okay yes very clear
it's the third we'll see it it's coming
up right here oh yeah you're right
there's absolutely three pumps there
oh uh apologies to all those watching
with young children uh clearly
unintentional
I'm Dave sassen alongside Jeff Worthing
and welcome to the 2013 East West Bowl
where we're going to be watching some of
the best college athletes in the nation
try to put last year's spectacle to
shame that's right Dave it won't be easy
but this year's seniors certainly will
be trying to give last year's Stars a
run for their money let's check out the
team starting with the players from the
East
[Music]
cause Nestor Smith Ruckus University
ellipses quarter University of Alabama
now aquila's deal why LSU bismo Funyuns
Florida State University
[Music]
of Louisville quitting the Todd Business
University of Tennessee
Ole Miss crocodile blip Auburn
University Julius Boozer
the you Muscatine Tristan University of
Michigan
fall Trail plugins University of
Arkansas
see you
cartoons plural Virginia Tech Jammy
Jammy Jammy V Ohio State University
fudge
some of the big stories this year the
meteoric rise of the Pez poopsie and
let's not forget about Heisman winner
Jammy Jammy Jammy and remember you can't
talk about 2013 without bringing up
fudge everybody's talking about fudge at
350 pounds this running back is almost
Unstoppable the whole year you're right
I could talk about fudge all day but
first let's meet the players from the
West
[Music]
equine ducklings
Indiana University Purdue University
Indianapolis Daw historius La mistorius
Utah State University
iwakonias Sigourney Junior Steam
Oklahoma State University Exquisite team
bubbleish Winslow University of Nebraska
-lakanaka hakanakahika hakafaka
University of Hawaii King Prince
chambermaid
Baylor University
but Jennifer Dynasty University of
Colorado
[Music]
University of Arizona Harvard University
DeVry University
[Laughter]
[Music]
Navy Surplus Store Wing Days
online classes first name last name
College University God homeschool
[Music]
squeeze
Santa Monica College
Benedict's Cumberbatch
Oxford University A.A Ron bolake
Morehouse College
[Music]
hi everybody I'm Dave stassen alongside
Jeff Worthing and welcome to the annual
East West Bowl as we get ready to watch
some of the best college players in the
nation showcase their skills in a
classic showdown between east and west
and there really are some characters on
this year's squads Arthur Jeff that's
right Dave it does seem like the most
flamboyant personalities came to the
Forefront and they are here let's meet
the players from the East
to Marcus Williams University of Georgia
T.J Jackson Wayne State University
Tavares Miss King Merrimack College
Royals smoochie Wallace University Miami
the squarius green Junior University of
Notre Dame Ibrahim Moy Zeus University
of Tennessee at Chattanooga Jack Marius
taxtheratrix Michigan State University
the Isaiah T buildings Coastal Carolina
University The Jasper probing Crux III
South Carolina State University
Leos Maxwell Jr East Carolina University
Javaris Jamar jamaris and Lamar
University of Middle Tennessee the voyne
shower handle
University of Southern Mississippi him
go MC kringleberry Penn State University
Le carpetron Duke Marriott
Florida Atlantic University
[Music]
University of South Florida Xmas Jackson
flexing waxing California University of
Pennsylvania
we're going to be looking for big plays
all game long from tyrol Smoochy Wallace
and let's not forget the tight ends
Ibraham moisus and hengel mccringleberry
they've both had amazing season that's
right Jeff now let's meet the players
from the West
[Music]
vegetarian Jefferson
Texas A M the cluster her doctor
University of Wisconsin swarvathon L
Goodings flat Saskatchewan University
quadruple Quattro San Jose State
University also my tires buckshank
Stanford University these are 12 washing
beers
Jones college
Shakira Quan TGIF Carter University of
Northern Arizona X Wayne at aliciousness
Missouri Western State University
sequester grundle plit MD Adam State
scores Philosoraptor malloy's South
Dakota State University TJ AJ RJ
backslashes fourth the fifth Albion
College
[Music]
San Diego State University donkey teeth
Boise State University torque
Louis
Nevada state
Penitentiary the player formerly known
as Mouse cop
University of Missouri Columbia Dan
Smith BYU
[Music]